Whenever you're working with core data,
a mysterious words start
showing up every now and then.
Fault if you see log
messages about fault.
Set your worries aside
it's not your fault and
everything is okay,
before we explain what a fault is and
why it makes core data such
a useful tool for iOS development.
Let's go back to table views for
a second.
A table view never loads
all the cells at once,
that would be incredibly wasteful.
Think of a fetch request that
returns one million objects and
you tried to display
them in a table view.
Would one million cells
be created at once?
Of course not.
A table view is smarter than that.
The table view by using
its data source will only
load the cells that
are visible in a given moment.
This means that cells are created
on a per need basis which
optimizes performance and memory usage.
This is such a brilliant idea that it's
used in many other places in Coco,
such as collection views.
Let's take a look at one.
When I scroll up and a cell disappears
it gets removed from memory.
This is only the view but
wouldn't it be great to have the model
object being displayed in the cell,
to be removed from memory
once it's not needed anymore?
That's exactly what core
data does by using folds.
So hang on there and
we'll explain it in the next video.